dans la comédie musicale Paul Joey Kim
retrouve Sinatra et fait jeu égal avec
la grande britaeworth puis elle obtient
le rôle de sa vie dans Vertigo devant la
caméra d'Alfred Hitchcock
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
se comporta avec moi comme un vrai
gentleman mais sans doute ne t'ai-je pas
son type de femme personne ne savait ce
qui se cache derrière son éternel
sourire le scénario baigne pourtant dans
ce même climat de romantisme vénéneux et
obsessionnel qui caractérise les
meilleurs films noirs de toppreminger
mais si les préoccupations d'Hitchcock
pouvaient parfois rejoindre celle de
l'Autrichien leur méthode de travail
avec les acteurs n'avaient que peu de
points communs en 1959 je signe un
remarquable drame judiciaire dans
Autopsie d'un meurtre ou James Stuart
horrifia les bien-pensant en excédant
une petite culotte devant un tribunal
une fois encore le scandale déclenché
par les censeurs se retourna contre eux
et le film fut un triomphe
j'apparaissais même sur la bande-annonce
preuve de la grande notoriété dont je
jouissais à Hollywood au début des
années 60 je réalise plusieurs grosses
productions peu inspirer après les de la
naissance d'Israël retracée dans Exodus
j'explore les caves du Vatican dans une
nouvelle super production affichant un
casting international le cardinal il
faudra que je retourne vers des
productions au budget et aux ambitions
plus modestes pour retrouver toute la
vigueur de mes chefs-d'œuvre des années
40 et 50 dans Harry Sandown je traite
avec justesse du racisme dans les États
du Sud et je me réconcilie avec les
cinéphiles en 1980 je tourne mon dernier
film et en 1986 je tire le rideau sans
savoir réellement pourquoi j'avais tant
de mal à travailler avec les femmes tant
pis mon oeuvre parle maintenant pour moi
en 1964 je trouve un nouveau grand rôle
celui de la gentille prostituée dans
Kiss Me stupide de Billy Wilder
[Musique]
l'échec commercial de ce film va briser
ma carrière le vieil ennemi
d'autopreninger la Légion catholique
pour la défense a en effet ordonné le
boycott total de cette comédie jugée
offensante pour l'institution du mariage
[Musique]
je fais un retour remarqué devant les
caméras en 1978 dans le miroir se brisa
d'après Agatha Christie j'ai enfin
trouvé la paix intérieure qui me
manquait après mon travail avec Auto
Preminger je n'ai plus jamais renié ce
que j'étais préférant quitter ce monde
pour vivre en harmonie dans le mien avec
embrasse-moi idiot et Vertigo l'homme au
bras d'or et le troisième chef-d'oeuvre
qui entretiendra pour les cinéphiles le
souvenir de la beauté et du talent de
Kim Novak on le sera sans doute pas
comment fut créé hors caméra le
personnage de Molly mais on oubliera
jamais le regard fragile et doux de Kim
Novak filmé par la caméra d'un auto
Preminger qui se cherche toujours
[Musique]